when people asked me what my favorite
game is five nights at Freddy's 4 now
always oh it's such a good game 9 out of
10 9 out of 10 10 out of 10 I play a ton
of horror games and most of the time
they research a cheap gem scarce
have you played an F once do you know
what an F is five nights at Freddy's is
the best game ever on this planet there
will never be a game that is better than
five nights at Freddy's [ __ ] you
what is this shocker
all right let's give it a go well it
can't be worse than flyff first floor
ignited Freddie what did I ignite
exactly elect five objects within one
minute wait the timer's going down oh my
god I can move Oh Oh what dude this
looks extra cool hey chair how you doing
ready oh my god
oh my god
Wow Jesus Christ oh my god
it just starts from nowhere okay I need
to go like five objects what kind of
objects are we talking about oh but no
job oh my god I'm a [ __ ] and [ __ ]
get scared by a poster I got scared
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
fast you hear that they hear the
footsteps is [ __ ] scary as [ __ ] oh my
god I try to be cool in the internship
and engine I just lost my boss Murli oh
god I gotta gotta gotta gotta god stop
chasing me you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god I
hear he runs to [ __ ] this is what Matt
for should have been this the reason I
got so disappointed when the last one
came up you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] poster
it's because he didn't change anything
up in the game there's this the same
game over and over the first map game
was amazing
I'm not joking it was a great game but
then we just got the same game over and
over and over but people kept buying it
and any form of criticism the fanbase
would just [ __ ] all over you and be like
no Snap is the greatest game
Oh God oh god you see the [ __ ] eyes
the eyes lit up
oh god oh god
yes oh stop chasing me what am I
supposed to pick out their plan this is
the plan
what is it oh I got one I got two okay
okay three more three more three more
random objects oh god I can't tell
what do you think I'm scared when you
think I'm some [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was that piece of [ __ ] do you can
choose if you want to play with Freddie
oh my god I want to play with chica
she's my BAE [ __ ] Bonnie just could take
a quick break okay nice to meet you
I see that you came here for a yeah yeah
the [ __ ] just happened
all right let's play some art whoa this
is different what the [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] not dude oh my god no
okay five objects I only have five
minutes I mean 30 seconds that's like
not a lot of time dude where are the
objects this is like a hardcore slender
dude we're finebros we're [ __ ] fine
what are you scared
you think I'm scared do I look like some
scared scared ass [ __ ] who gets scared
I don't get scared
of video games I have never been scared
of a video game my entire life
video games are for [ __ ] [ __ ] and
people with tiny balls hey Bonnie
you got a great fun if you know what I
mean
I'm top I am not scared where the [ __ ]
are all the items main
Oh
oh my [ __ ] toe Jesus Christ man down
medic I bust my toe the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you man how are you no I'm not
good I'm doing [ __ ] can you stop talking
to my [ __ ] face [ __ ] you you're not
shaming [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is your
problem she pretending to she this is a
[ __ ] outrage another one you think
I'm scared you think I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh Jeff let it fit down now come after
me for I'm gonna finish this game if
there's a last thing I let collect five
objects collect five what am i homeless
what am i some [ __ ] thief no wonder
he wants to kill me I'm stealing all
these [ __ ] if I ain't own a head a
little bit this yeah blah feet died of
it hey hey it's me
poor teapot [ __ ]
was i gay yeah yeah yeah I'm ready for
more where the [ __ ] am I
you can't stop I'm a force of nature
can't stop me I'm putting pop [ __ ] this
is what I do this is my life and I'm
living it I found an object okay we
found one for more baby
laughs it's my favorite game thank you
for watching this is honestly really
cool it's cool to see fans taking a
really cool concept and turning it into
something else
maybe this will inspire Scott to do
something different with this next title
I don't know I hope so
either way that was really cool if you
enjoyed watching leave a like did you
get scared
leave a comment I don't care and it's
always stay awesome am i sweating can
someone put on a fan what the [ __ ] is
that
[ __ ] the [ __ ] come from the Saline holy
[ __ ] sophie is the swell [ __ ]
roommate man that's